well there's so many directions i want
to take this but i think it probably
would be wise to just
spend a few minutes talking about what
what
like sort of defining our terms like
what is sleep like going through the
various stages and kind of
explaining the terrain yeah so
sleep um in humans at least and uh most
mammals and birds is broadly separated
into two main types that you'd mentioned
on the one hand we have non-rapid eye
movement sleep
or non-rem sleep for short and
non-rem sleep has been further
subdivided into
four separate stages in fact um
unimaginatively called stages one
through four
a creative bunch clearly your sleep
researchers um decreasing in their depth
of sleep
so stages three and four are those
really deep stages of restorative sleep
that's what your sort of you know sleep
tracker would say that's deep sleep
stages one and two they're light sleep
and then on the other hand we have rapid
eye movement sleep or rem sleep
um named not after the popular michael
stipe band of the
1980s but after these strange horizontal
shuttling eye movements that occur under
the eyelid as you're in this stage
and rem sleep is the stage during which
we principally dream
and that's where you have your most sort
of florid most narrative
hallucinogenic emotional sort of dreams
and it turns out that those two types of
sleep non-rem
and rem will play out in this incredible
battle for brain domination throughout
the night
and that um sort of cerebral war
is going to be won and lost every 90
minutes
and then replayed every 90 minutes at
least in humans
and that creates this standard cycling
architecture
of sleep what's fascinating though and
we actually still don't quite understand
why
is that the ratio balance of those two
types of sleep non-rem and rem
changes across the night and what i mean
by that is
in the first half of the night the
majority of those
90-minute cycles are comprised of lots
of deep non-rem sleep
but very little rem sleep and so as you
push through to the second half of the
night
now that seesaw balance will actually
shift and instead you get much more
rapid eye movement sleep particularly in
the last couple of hours
and it's not just important to sort of
understand one's
sleep but understanding that structure
has implications real life
so let's say for example that i normally
get my eight hours sort of
and uh it doesn't you know we can speak
about timing on the clock face and what
makes sense for people but
let's say that i'm a guy who goes to bed
at 10 and i typically wake up at 6.
but today i've got an early morning
meeting or i want to sort of
cut my sleep short to get a jump start
on the day to get to the gym
and i wake up two hours early so i wake
up at four rather than six
how much sleep have i lost well i've
lost two hours from eight hours
so i've lost 25 percent of my sleep
well yes and no yes i've lost 25 percent
of my total sleep
but because rem sleep comes late in the
morning i may have lost
50 60 maybe even 70 percent of all of my
rem sleep
so it's not just sort of you know
academic to understand even though
it's fun for me but for for many people
it does have real world
implications the complexity of it is
fascinating i mean it
sleep really is right up there with
outer space and the depths of the ocean
in terms of it's it's it's mysteries and
you know the the idea that we're just
beginning to learn
what's actually going on and it's not a
matter
of i'm sure you get this question all
the time like what's more important rem
sleep or
non-rem sleep or what you know what's
the
you know the sort of significance of
being deprived of one over the other but
it's really the interplay of all of
these things
and the more complex you realize it to
be it becomes impossible
to consider that it's not crucial to all
facets of human
health that's right and you know when we
go back to that evolutionary story of
of how you know detrimental sleep is
as a state and it is let's let's face it
you know if there were any stage of
sleep that were not
important that mother nature could have
come in and excised
and had you you know doing all of these
benefits of wakefulness
i'm quite sure she would have and what
we've learned
is that every stage of sleep is
important different stages of sleep
perform different functions for the
brain and body
at different times of night and so yeah
i'll often get that question people will
say how can i get more deep sleep or how
can i get more
rem sleep and you know i often say well
why do you want more of that and they
say well isn't that the good stuff
and they're both absolutely critical
now i could make a scientific argument
that rem sleep could be a little bit
more important from
a simple mortality state because there
were studies done back in the 1980s with
rats and
they've actually never been replicated
again
i found them difficult to read i do
research in humans i don't do
animal research and i think they won't
be replicated for good reason
what they wanted to do is see if a lack
of sleep
is deathly is a lack of sleep fatal and
they had
three different flavors of the
experiment in the first they took rats
and they just deprived them of sleep
you know night and day after day night
and day after day and what they found is
that those rats died
within about 20 days so in other words
rats will die as quickly from a lack of
food as they will from a lack of sleep
that's how
fundamental it is then the two
additional flavors of the experiment
they selectively deprived them of either
just rapid eye movement sleep so that
they could get
just non-rem or they did the opposite
they just deprived them of
non-rem and gave them rem and firstly
both of those were fatal
but what was interesting is that the
rats died from
rem sleep deprivation within about 30 to
40 days
and they died from deep non-rem sleep
deprivation within about 50 or 60 days
so if we want to sort of do a coke pepsi
challenge between sort of you know
non-rem
and rem um which one wins out in the
mortality battle
it seems to be rem sleep and to me
that's interesting too
if you'd ask me where i would place my
bets
i would have said non-rem the reason is
because
non-rem came first if you look during
sort of the time
course of evolution of across phylogeny
non-rem sleep was the first sleep to
emerge and it was
only when we went from reptiles
amphibians and fish and then there was
that bifurcation
to birds and then mammals did the
evolution of rem sleep
emerge so rem sleep is the new kid on
the evolutionary block
and furthermore rem sleep evolved twice
independently in birds and mammals which
i find you know it's fascinating too
so to come back to your point i'm sorry
i'm drifting but
all stages of sleep are critical no one
stage of sleep you can do without
without
suffering detriment
[Music]
you